és akkor is ott voltam jeruzsálemben
mikor mikor kirobbant a háború és
először nem tudtam hogy mi van tehát az
első reakcióm az volt hogy hallottam
ilyen szirénnylázásokat meg nyilván
tudtam procedúrát hogy mit kell csinálni
tehát van egy ilyen páncélvé az ablakon
h be kellett húzzak é van egy olyan 60
másodpercünk hogy bemenjünk a biztonsági
szobába attól függüen hogy hol érünk
tehát hogyha valaki közelebb é gázához
akkor lehet hogy még kevesebb ha
távolabb akkor lehet hogy több mint 6
[Zene]
van sziasztok egy egész érdekes
epizóddal készülök most számotokra a
következő vendégem erős gáspár aki az én
személyes jó barátom volt osztálytársam
és együtt jártunk egyetemre is ő most
jelen pillanatban izraelben lakik és le
tudtunk ülni beszélgetni egyet arról
hogy milyen is volt neki megtapasztalni
ezt a háborút a háború kitöréséről
kérdeztem az akkori viszonyokról hogy
hogyan éli meg a mindennpjait ebben a
pillanatban és beszélgettünk arról a
vitalitásról erőről és optimizmusról ami
mindennek ellenére az izraeli népet
jellemzi egy egészen elképesztő
beszélgetés volt tartsatok
velünk hát üdvözllek a műsoromba gazsi
éppen azon gondolkoztam az előbb hogy 15
éve amikor még szabatársak voltunk vajon
gondoltuk-e volna hogy egyszer így
fogunk beszélgetni hogy az én műsoromba
foglak meghívni és te egy háború
sújtotta országban izraelben leszel
tényleg olyan minthogyha nem is velünk
történt volna ez hanem egy másik életben
történt
volna hogy emlékszel te vissza amúgy a a
csíszeredai évekre
köszönöm a meghívást és köszöntöm a
nézőket a csíszereda egy
ilyen kezdőpont az az életemben ott
születtem ott jártam iskolába
gyakorlatilag ott voltam gyerek és
azután ugye elkerültünk kolozsvárra és
azt nagyjából úgy tudnám összegezni hogy
ott kezdtem- el felnőni és akkor később
volt egy periódusom amikor éltem
budapesten
nem terveztem ott élni csak egy ilyen
átmeneti időszakra éltem ott azt úgy
mondanám hogy egy ilyen dobbantó volt
mondjuk hogy jőjek izraelbe de a az
izraellel való kapcsolatom az korábban
kezdődöttten hm igen hát most ezekről is
akarlak kérdezni többek között ezekről
lesz főként szó hogy mi történik most
izraelben és nálad bizonyos szempontból
jobb személyt akivel leülhetnék
beszélgetni a saját ismerősi körömből
nem is kaphatnék
úgyhogy kezdjük talán azzal hogy miért
is döntöttél úgy hogy izraelbe
kiköltözől több oka van tehát ez ez egy
folyamatnak a vége tehát ez nem nem úgy
történt hogy egyik percrő a másikra így
döntöttem tehát nézők kedvére elmondom
te jobban ismersz de a néző kedvére
elmondott pár dolgot magamról hogy adjak
egy ilyen kontextust hogy körülbelül mi
az ami ami ide vezetett szóval
elsősorban a a hitem a hitem szerint
keresztény vagyok
származásilag zsidó vagyok anyai ágon
de nem nőttem zsidó vallásba viszont
mindig olyan neveltetést kaptam hogy
hogy izrael párti tehát zsidó párti
neveltetést kaptam és annak ellenére
hogy nem jöttem vallásba mármint a zsidó
vallásba mindig érdekelt a dolog meg
olvastam róla gyerekkoromban olvastam
bibliát mármint hogy gyerekkoromban
kezdtem olvasni a tórát de de
ez hogy is mondjam nem voltam elég érett
ahhoz hogy ezt
hogy hogy sok mindent megértsek a orivba
belőle és ez egy ilyen folyamatnak a
folyamatnak a vége ami a hitemet illeti
az
az keresztény hitű vagyok viszont nem
nem tarttozom egyetlen valláshoz sem
tehát nem nem értek egyet azokkal a az
ideológiákkal amelyeket a különböző
nagyobb vallások
képviselnek szülítő szabadságot kaptam
tehát a szüleim nem tettek bele egyetlen
vallásba
se én döntöttem el hogy milyen hitet
követett tehát kiköltöztél budapestre és
hogyha jól emlékszem akkor jó párszor
meglátogattad
izraelt h hogy született meg ez a döntés
hogy ott is maradj véglegesen
izraelbe 2011-ben kezdtem
igazából járni izraelben volt egy ilyen
állom bennem hogy egyszer egyszer
kijövök meglátogatom izraelt és ez akkor
valósult meg mikor elkezdtem dolgozni
tehát 2011 novemberében azt hiszem akkor
még kolozsváron éltem tehát akkor még
teljesen kezd voltam és igazából az első
gyűjtött pénzemből tehát amikor annyi
pénzt összegyűjtöttem a a munkám eleén
hogy látható kezett lenni akkor akkor
kijöttem izraelbe tehát pénzem nagy
részét tehát az első fizetéseim nagy
részét arra kültöttem el hogy hogy
köttem izraelbe
tehát azt gondolom hogy a hogy az hogy
mi fontos nekünk nem feltétlenül az
dönti el hogy hogy a mit mondunk hogy
fontos hanem tranzakciókal vannak számlá
hagy m ho hova költöd el a pénzed igen
igen tehát dumálni sok mindenről lehet
de igazából ha akarod tudni egy ember
hogy mi fontos neki akkor megnézed hogy
mire tölti az idejét és mik a
tranzakciók a számlán igazából ez a
döntőszeré igen hát miért hoz miért
hozunk áldozatot valóban és a figyelmünk
az egy fajta áldozat és a pénzünk az egy
másik fajta áldozat de valójában
ugyanarról beszél hogy hogy hogy az
igazságot tükrözi számunkra miért
vagyunk hajlandóak áldozatot hozni és
akkor milyen volt a a az első
tapasztalataid izraelben mi milyen volt
ott
lenni neked az elején amikor még csak
egy egy két hetes periódusra mentél
meglátogatni izraelt
igazából úgy éreztem hogy hazajöttem az
első alkalommal tehát egy ilyen
visszatérés a gyökerekhez egy ilyen
ilyen érzésemhez
és nagyon érdekes volt
hogy hogy úgy is fogadtak minthogyha
hazajöttem volna tehát minden a
természet az emberek közvetlenek voltak
tehát hogy nagyon nagyon könnyen
alakítottam ki kapcsolatokat ezt
megfigyeltem tehát hogy leültem bárkivel
beszélgetni már olyan mély témákra
mentünk hogy azt hiszem hogy az európai
kultúrával el kell tölteni pár pár hetet
valakivel hogy olyan dolgokra
rákérdezzem milyen nyelven beszéltetek
gondolom angolul az elején nyilván nem
tudtam héberül az elején nem tudtam
héberül tehát angorul beszélt mindegy
aránylag mindenki jól beszél angorul
tehát még a gyerekek is gyerekek is
egész jól beszélnek angolul meg
izraelnek egy része ugye itt a környező
államokból is származik meg egy része
európából jött a zsidóságnak haza szóval
szóval így a az angol nyelv az nem egy
nem egy probléma ha valaki nem tudja
értenni angolul akkor tud oroszul átaláb
ez a felállás euros oroszul igen tehát
nagyon sok az oroszsidó it a a feleségem
a
oroszul beszél és
megfigyelem sokszor hogy bemegyünk egy
üzletbe vagy bárhova vyun izraelbe
hogyha ha véletlenül valaki nem beszél
angolul és vagy
vagy észreveszi hogy a héberünk az nem
nem tökéletes teszem fel akkor akkor
egybő megszólalnak orosszul ez egy
nagyon gyakori a feleségeninek a vonása
észreveszik általában hogy hogy hogy
fehér oroszországból származik tehát
ezt a hogy is mondjam kulturálisan
észreveszik és akkor egy egybe
megszólanak oroszul tehát ez egy ilyen
orosz angol héber itt mindegyik nyelv
működik persze heéber az alap a amióta
jobban beszélem azt gyakorlom de mikor
az elején voltam itt akkor akkor nyilván
angolul angolul beszéltem ez egy ilyen
folyamat volt a az életemben tehát hogy
kijöttem először és azt éreztem hogy
hogy hogy mondom hogy ha hazaértem volna
és
még el se mentem innen és egyből azon
gondolkoztam hogy mikor fogok ide
vissönni tehát azon agyaltam míg itt
voltam hogy hogy én ide vissza akarok
még jönni és
utána visszajöttem
2012-ben néhány barátommal egy ilyen
sátras kirándulásra és akkor utána
mindig mindig ez egy ilyen hogy is
mondjam ilyen jó értelemben vett
függőséget okozott tehát mindig
terveztem előre hogy most voltam
augusztusban akkor következőben jövök
jövő márciusban például és akkor melyik
mikor költöztél ki végleg
2022 júliusában költöztem ki hm de
előtte 12szer voltam izraelben egy
turista
tehát nagyjából egy évben egyszer
kijöttem átlagban hogyha volt valami
volt egy olyan if hogy nem jöttem ki
mert nem tudom más dolgom volt de vagy
másra voltam elfoglalva de vagy
zsúfoltabb éven volt de átlagban megvolt
a hy egyszer köttem a 2011 meg 22 között
volt hogy
kétszer ez nagyon érdekes hogy egy olyan
nyitott közösséget írsz le amire nem
gondoltam volna hogy tényleg ilyen
nyitott ez a közösség egyrészt
keresztényként te tapasztaltál-e
valamilyen elutasítást a
környezetedbe nem tapasztaltam semmit
mert én nem próbálom ráerőltetni a
hitemet senkire igazából tehát én de én
fordítva értem hogy hogy hogy hogy
izraelben a
zsidók esetleg elzárnak vagy vagy
elutasítanak amiatt mert nem zsidó
vagy ők elfogadnak engem zsidónak iv
anyai ágon vagyok anyai ágon vannak
zsidó felm tehát elfogadnak ők téged
zsidó nak annak ellenére hogy hogy te
kereszténynek tartod magad aki a
különbség van a a jog között ami ami jog
létezik az állában és a vallási jog
között és a a zsidó vallás szerint az a
zsidó aki anyajában
zsidó és és emiatt hogy is mondjam van
egy ilyen testvériség érzés tehát hogy
engem nem néznek idegen idegennek mikor
én beszélek itt valakivel tehát én én én
úgy is érzem magamat hogy ide tartozom
itthon vagyok
ühüm szóval hogy hogy az én szereottip
képem őszintén szólva az volt hogy egy
ennyire forró talajon levő országnak a
az attitűdje az elutasítás az idegenek
fele akik nem héberek és nem mondjam úgy
hogy hát zsidó születésileg de pont
amiről mesélsz az pont az ellenkezője
hogy nyitottan fogadtak annak ellenére
hogy héberősen beszéltél annak ellenére
hogy nem hát külföldről jöttél
nyitottan fogadtta el de de ez ez nem
egy ez nem egy y kió eseti sok minden
kijön úgymond külföldről mer a a izrael
a zsidóságnak a hazája tehát hogy egy
zsidó mikor aliázik akkor hazajön tehát
ez ez egy elég elég gyakori eset tehát
hogy hogy valaki külföldre jön az az az
az abban nincsen semmi kilévó itt tehát
hogy hogy igazából azt szoktuk egymástól
megkérdezni hogyha egy ismeretlennel
találkozok hogy te honnan jöttél vagy
vagy te már itt születtél vagy ét vagy
vagy mikor aliászná tehát ilyen ilyen
kérdések merülnek fel ez ilyen ilyen
alapbeszélgetés ha például beősz egy
taxivba vagy valakivel csak szóbáz és mi
a helyzet a a muzulmánokkal szemben az a
nyitottságuk ilyenkor hogyan érvényesül
a
zsidóknak nekünk nincs dolgunk velük
igazából
tehát azt azt kell megérteni a a
keresztényeknek hogy a zsidóság az nem
egy térítő vallás a zsidóság nem akar
senkit megtéríteni sehova senkit nem
akar rávenni hogy zsidó legyen maximum
annyi
[Zene]
annyi van benne hogy a hogy a a nem
vallásos zsidók például mint én nem
vallásos zsidónak számítok hogyha egy
vallásos zsidó kint van az utcán vagy
beszél velem akkor ő érdekelt abban hogy
engem közelebb vigyen a valláshoz de ő
egy meglévő zsidót akar egy meglévő
zsidóban akarja a zsidóságot
felibreszteni de de semmi éppen nem akar
valakit meghghódítani vagy nem akar
konvertálni vagy több tagot gyűjteni
tehát hogy igazából ennyi van hogy a
meglévő zsidókban ébreszték fel a
zsidóságot és a
a azok a zsidók akik nem élnek még
izraelbe hogy jöljenek haza van egy
ilyen bátorítás de de semmi dolguk nincs
a a muzulmánokkal vagy más vallásulakkal
izraelbe több vallás van és izraelben
teljes a vallászabadság tehát mindenki
ugy akkor máá ahogy akarja senki nem
zavar
senkit erre nem gondoltam volna igen hát
a amióta kitört a háború azóta
úgy megfogalmazódott bennem hogy
szeretnék leülni veled beszélgetni főleg
amióta a podcastemet is elindítottam
azóta szerettem volna egy kicsit
mélyebben belemenni a témába és hogyha
nincs ellenedre akkor egy pár dolgot
kérdeznék ezzel kapcsolat abzolt
a október 7e előtt érződött-e valami már
a lev őbe valami feszültség amiből
esetleg következettél arra hogy valami
történhet vagy történni
fog nem azt kell hogy mondjam hogy nem
de mivel hogy a realitás talajan állunk
tehát ezért nem hítjük magunkat tehát
tudjuk hogy ez egy olyan hely ahol
bármikor bármi történhet tehát hogyha
hosszabb távó kérdezed akkor azt mondom
hogy mindig érződik valami tehát mindig
mindig érződik hogy bármikor bármi
történhet de hogy konkrét jeleket
október előt nem nem észeltünk tehát ez
egy ilyen nagyon nagyon hirtelenjevő
dolog volt izraelben amúgy is jellemző
hogy
hogy nem érződik ez a háborús hangulat
amit a amit a média átad az izraelen
kívülieknek szóval azt figyeltem meg
hogy akik sok hírt néznek izraelről és
nem élnek itt vagy vagy még talán sosem
voltak itt azok egy kicsit úgy nézik
izraelt hogy itt itt csak a sivatagba
lőjük egymást meg meg menekülünk a
rakéták előt tehát van egy ilyen
képzetünk mert van egy limitált számú
gondolatunk mindenkinek van egy limitált
számú gondolata egy napra izraelről való
gondolatain szám még limitáltabb vagy
aki aki semmilyen módon nem kötődik ide
annak annak még limitáltabbak a
gondolatai és hogyha ezeket a
gondolatokat a média azzal tölti meg
hogy hogy kilőttek x rakétát amit
kivédett a a vaskupola vagy nem tudom
milyen terrortámadást történt
akkor el tudom képzelni hogy egy
kívülállomnak az a gondolata izraelről
hogy itt itt nonstop itt nonstop öljük
egymást meg lövöldözünk de a valóságban
egy teljesen teljesen békés helynek
tűnik hogyha egy turista kijön ebb nem
fog semmit érezni abszolút semmit érezni
még egy pillanatra menjünk vissza az
október 7-ére mert érdekel hogy te
hogyan élted meg ezt az október 7-ei az
egy szombat volt amúgy október 7 igen
szombat volt igen tehát direkt úgy
időzítették hogy egy sabat legyen egy
olyan amikor amikor nem nem számítanak
vagy vagy vagy vagy hogy
a a sátoros ünnep akkor járt le is jött
a a sz háóra tehát a ne nem tudom hogy
hogy pont ez volt-e a szándék hogy pont
így ünnepre időzítsék de de mindenképp
egy olyan időpontot találtak amikor hogy
is mondjam nyugvóponton volt az ország
üüm amikor te meghallottad emlékszel-e
hogy hol voltál éppen mit csináltál
persze felér lötem a
szirénákra ak akkor jeruzsálembbe nétem
tehát én én mikor kijöttem akkor
jeruzsálembe értem július 2022-től
egészen idén nyárig mivel az idénz idén
nősültem és szükség volt egy nagyobb
lakásra feleségem telavéba élt amí amíg
ismerkedtünk szükségünk volt egy nagyobb
lakásra és ki akartunk próbálni egy új
helyet ezért most most átköltöztünk
netániába de az időm nagy részét
jeruzsálemen étem és akkor is ott voltam
jeruzsálemben mikor mikor kirobbant a
háború
és először nem tudtam hogy mi van tehát
az első reakcióm az volt hogy hallottam
ilyen szirénázásokat meg meg mivel rég
nem hallottam előtte ilyen szirénát
izraelbe ez így úgy el voltam szóva tőle
tehát hogy mikor kijöttem azóta nem nem
emlékszem semmilyen rakétállásra a
közelembbe és
akkor nyilván tudtam a procedúrát hogy
mit kell csinálni tehát van egy ilyen
páncélé az ablakon hogy be kellett
húzzak azt érdemes tudni hogy izraelbe
az újépítésű épületeket úgy építik hogy
van egy ilyen biztonsági szoba
amelyiknek amelyiknek vastagabb a fala
van egy keményebb ajtó és van egy
páncélvédő az ablak k előt amit amit el
szoktunk húzni tehát hogy és van egy
olyan 60 másodpercünk hogy bemenjünk a
biztonsági szobába attól függüen hogy
hol érünk tehát hogyha valaki közelebb
ér gázához akkor lehet hogy még kevesebb
ha távolab akkor lehet hogy több mint 6
van mikor volt az utolsó amikor így ebbe
a biztonságos ába kellett
meneküljetek a háború előtt nekem nem
volt ilyen tehát turistaként volt am it
volt volt hogy valami rakétázás volt de
nem a közelemben volt tehát nekem nem
volt hí hogy be kellett meneküljek de
tudtam a
procedúrát és mennyire gyakori ez hogy
be kell vonuljatok ebbe a biztonságos
zónába ezen a héten volt rá példa ezen a
héten nem volt mert most pont ilyen
szünetet tartértetjük a háborút úgymond
tehát a mi mikor volt utoljára
utoljára egy olyan négy hete volt aiszem
egy olyan négy hete igen igen tehát a a
háború alatt is én nem nem szeretem
dramatizálni a dolgokat tehát a médiának
az a dolga hogy dramatizálni én próbálom
próbálom a realitást látadni tehát
voltak olyan időszakok amikor igen
többször be kellett vonuljun de de
ugyanakkor elteltek hetek van olyan hogy
hónapok is en kellett bevonulun tehát
attól függen hogy mennyire vagy közel
gázához vagy mennyire vagy közel közel
libanonhoz ez nagyjából ettől függően
kell bevonulja a biztonsági szobába
nekem az zeren volt a zere zerején be
kellett vonulun párszor jeruzsálembe is
teraléba szerintem még többször be
kellett vonuljanak
igazából jeruzsálem nincs rosszul
pozicionálva a háború szempontjából
jeruzsálemben mások a kihívások tehát
légvonalban azt hiszem egy olyan 70 km
gázától és a a vaskupol rendszer nagy
eséllyel már meg fogja rak ákat mielőtt
mielőtt elne jeruzsálemhez jeruzsálemben
a nagyobb kihívás az hogy van egy
nagyobb szám arab lakosság és nagyobb a
terror veszi az utcán például tát hogy
kiegyensúlyozódik de aki például délen
lakik askeron asdód ami askeron az egyik
legközelebbi nagyváros gázához ők ők
viszont sokszor le kellett volondolnak a
biztonsági szobáb és ugyanúgy a háború
második felében amikor a hezbolla
aktivizálta magát akkor akkor hajfán
volt például több probléma ilyen
szempontból tehát ez ez egy nagyon
dinamikusan változó dolog egy
kiszámíthatatlanul változó dolog de ez
igazából ezt tesz erősé meg megtanultunk
kni
ezzel mentálisan nagyon fontos hogy hogy
van van egy probléma de nem a nem ne
akadjunk le a problémán hanem
fókuszáljunk arra hogy hogyan reagálunk
rá tehát hogy hogy itt izraelben ez egy
rutin dolog tehát mi nem nem csinálunk
semmi drámát jön két raké itt a most
például akkor hagyom az intert befutok a
szobába feleségemel bezárom a kiszedem
az ablakokat ki szoktam szedni az
ablakokat a is a procedúra része hogyha
ha valami olyan helyen csapódna akkor az
üvegszilágok ne vágjanak el vagy valami
ilyesmit ezt alapból kiszedem az
ablakokat behúzom a páncél védő be
bepattintom az ajtót és benőünk miután
el eltűntek a robbanások vagy nem
hallunk semmi robbanás akkor akkor utána
utána még várunk egy egy pár percedben
ez is a procedúra része mert még
szilákok lejöhetnek
fentről de ezt nem ezt nem úy éjük meg
hogy ezt nem úgy érjük meg hogy most
mekkora dráma történt tehát mondok neked
egy konkrét példát tehát hogy egy reggel
reggelizün és akkor jöttek a rakét
befutottunk becsuktunk elvégeztem
mindent ami szükséges volt bent voltunk
egy 10 percet kimentünk és folytattuk a
reggeli nincs semmit
dráma lefőztük a h minden minden ment
tovább tehát hogy nincs idő ezzel
agyalni hogy hogy most mi történt és ez
a az izraeli társadalmat általában
jellemzi vagy pedig ti vagytok ilyen
nyugodtak nem nem nem semmiképpen nem
vagyunk ilyen hősök ilyen szempontbó ez
az izrael izraeli társadalomról
jellemző telavinban vannak olyanokra
példák hogy például bulit szerveznek
biztonsági
szobába tehát itt itt van egy olyan
mentalitás hogy nem engedhetjük meg az
ellenségnek hogy röhögjön
rajtunk tehát hogyha történik egy
terrortámadás
például nem engedhetjük meg hogy
röhögjenek rajtunk hogy hogy mi üresek
az utcánk
kimegyünk kimegyünk utána és és ha
tömegesen megyen ki az ad egy ilyen erőt
mondjam ú ez egy ez egy nagyon érdekes
dolog felolvasni azt az idézetet amit a
az újságcikből választottam ki amit
írtál egy évvel ezelőtt a a a har a
népébe az izraeli társadalomról érdemes
tudni hogy itt nem kerüljük a
konfrontációt sokkal nagyobb a
közvetlenség és a lazaság nincsenek
feleslegesen eltúlzott illemszabályok
nem kerekítjük sokat a dolgokat
kimondjuk amit akarunk és úgy ahogy
akarjuk mindegy hogy ki mit gondol és
mindegy ki hogyan reagálja le az
agyunkból gravitációval leesik a
gondolat és azonnal kijön a szánkon
nincs filter sok vita van a különböző
társadalmi csoportok között viszont
amikor a az ország bajban van akkor az
olyan szervezettséget és egységet
mutatunk fel mint senki más a világon ez
történik most a háború alatt is van egy
szép dolog a háború árnyékában amit a
média nem mutat be mert ez nem hoz annyi
nézettséget mint a gázai képek izraelben
érezhető hogy mindenki használja a
tehetségét befolyását pénzét idejét az
ország érdekében anélkül hogy valaki
erre megkérte volna a háború első napján
a külföldön tartózkodó izraeliek
megrohanták a repülőtereket hogy gyorsan
haz ha jöhessenek segíteni az országot
függetlenül attól hogy behívták őket
aznap a hadseregbe vagy sem mintegy
300000 izraeli készült elhagyni az
otthonát délről és északról a hamas és a
hezbollák támadásai miatt a
biztonságosabb részeken élő helyi
családok és hotelek pillanatok alatt
befogadták őket étterem tulajdonosok
veszik a személyzetüket viszik a
személyzetüket délre és főznek a
katonáknak ingyen fodrászok mennek
önkéntesen délre is levágják a katonák
haját zenészek mennek délre énekelnek a
katonáknak van egy komikus ismerősöm aki
jár fellépni jeruzsálembe a délről
evakuált családoknak hogy kicsit
felettesse a nehéz helyzetüket ismert
színészek sportolók művészek használják
a befolyásukat hogy kiálljanak izrael
mellett a médiában van egy hely
telavivban ahol a túszul ejtett
izraeliek családjai szoktak összegyűlni
sokan kimennek hozzájuk naponta segíteni
az ügyüket sok helyen van kir
kiragasztva a túszok képe a lakosság
ezzel gyakor nyomást a politikusokra
hogy tegyék meg a maximumot a túszok
hazahozataláért párhuzamosan megy ez a
figyelemfelhívás a túszokért online és
külföldön is sokan önkéntes munkát
ajánlanak fel vagy pénzt adományoznak a
déliek és a katonák segítése céljából
facebook és whatsappos csoportokban
szerveződnek az emberek segítségét kérve
és felajánlva ez a sok aprónak látszó
dolog összeadódik és stabilitást ad
mindenkinek fontos hogy a hadsereg az
áldozatok családja a sérültek a
túszuljtettek családja és az evakuált
családok érezzék hogy egység és erő van
mögöttük az utcákon amúgy sem szokott
hiány lenni izraeli zászlókból de most
sokkal több van talán még a függetlenség
napján sem volt ennyi zászló üzletek
éttermek kávézók teszik ki büszkén az
izraeli zászlót az egész ország egységes
mindenki a helyén van és teszi a dolgát
nagyjából ez a helyi hangulat itt
izraelben
itt rengeteg információt leírtál ebben a
ebben az újságcikben ebbe a ebben a
részben ezt mikor írtad ezt az
újságcikket tavaly novemberben keresett
meg valaki a halgító népétől mer
kíváncsi volt hogy milyen a helyzet itt
izraelben és nyilván mindenki el tud el
tudja olvasni a híreket általában hogy
hány rakéta volt kilőve meg kivédve meg
hányan haltak meg ezt mindenki tudja de
ezt én egyik hírbe se olvastam amit
leírtál értem de de azt akarom mondani
hogy amiről a hírek szólnak az az az
pont az ami a maximális figyelmet vonzza
és nem feltétlenül az ami a lényeg
tehát politikusok mit deklaráltak vagy
mit mondtak
de milyen fényképeket csináltak tehát
igazából errő erről szólnak a erről
szólnak a hírek és
én meg akartam mutat atni ezt a
láthatatlan részét hogy nem csak annyi
van hogy hogy itt van mit tudom amerika
és izrael szövetséges akkor akkor ezzel
le van rendezve hogy ezér erős izrael
hanem egyrészt izraelnek van egy nagyon
erős hadserege de az erős hadsereg
mögött ál egy nagyon nagyon erős
társadalom mind mentálisan lelkileg sok
sok szempontból nagyon erős társadalom
és ezen a társadalmon belül vannak viták
vannak töréspontok viszont ilyen krízis
helyzetekben igenis nagyon nagyon nagy
az egység igazából nem is engedhetnénk
meg magunknak hogy ne legyünk egységesek
háús helyzeten de ez nagyon érdekes mert
hogy ha valaki kívülről nézi hogy vannak
tüntetések itt például meg vannak ilyen
balhé tehát hogy is mondjam itt a az
izraeli társadalom elég balhés mondjam
tehát hogyha valami zavarja akkor
egy-kettőre kimegy tüntetni az utcára
tehát nem várja meg
hogy nem nem várja megint a hogy is
mondjam a kelet-európai társadalmak hogy
diktátor nagyon kinője magát és akkor
akkor majd
mit tudom mint romániábó kilövik egy
golyóval például tehát hogy itt az
emberek hamarabb kimutatják az
érzelmeiket tehát nem hogy is mondjam
nem engedik az emberek hogy hogy bennük
maradjon akár akár öröm akár gyű tehát
ez ez egy jellemző ennek a társadalomnak
és
[Zene]
azt hiszem hogy ez az ami okozza a az
egységet is más szempontból tehát tudom
egy kicsit erentmondás nak tűnik az hogy
hogy vannak viták izraelben és hogy
valaki megnézi a tüntetéseket akkor hogy
van itt tség hogyha tüntetések vannak ez
a kérdés merül fel úgy úy úgy van egység
hogy hogy
hogy hogy kimondjuk a dolgokat tehát
hogy hogy lefolytatjuk a vitákat tehát
emiatt az általános bizalmi szint egymás
iránt magasabb mert bíztak abban hogy ha
valami baj van akkor felszólalnak az
emberek ha nem szólalnak fel akkor
minden van egy egy házasság hogy hogy
hogy az nem okoz egységet hogyha
mindenki elfot mindent tehát hogy akkor
nem lesz egység hogy hogy mindenki ilyen
szépen mosolyog meg mindenki szépen
elfot minden sokszor jobb egy veszekedés
akár sokszor jobb egy veszekedés és
akkor utána eljött a kéz egy olyan
pontra hogy oké ezt gondolom én ezt
gondolod te és akkor van valami alapján
ami ami alapján egységet teremtsünk mert
megbeszéltük a dolgokat én azt gondolom
hogy például romániában is meg
magyarországon ez az egyik fő probléma
hogy hogy az egység azért nincs mert
mert az emberek nem elég konfrontatívak
nem eléggé válják fel a véleményüket
egymásra például nagyon hangosak
facebookon de de lustán kimenni tüntetni
és ez ez ez okozza azt ez ez okozza azt
a látszólag ellentmondásos dolgot hogy
én izraelben több mosolygó embert láttok
mint magyarországon vagy
romániában az emberek sokkal
pozitívabbak és ez nem egy ilyen nem egy
ilyen
hogy is mondjam
hamis pozitív pozitívság hanem hanem
mivel lerendeztük a konfliktusokat
kibeszéltük a problémáinkra nem kell
magunkba fot folytsuk tehát mondjam úgy
hogy nem rththat semmi érzelem bennünk
ami miatt zmálunk kellene ezért
megengedhetjük magunknak hogy mosolygun
tehát én én úgy látom hogy ez az
összefüggés és
én azt ért azt érzem hogy a például
kelet-európai társadalmakban ez részben
a kommunizmus miatt is részben népvé
miatt nem tudom hogy az az emberek sok
mindent magukba folytanak és ezért látz
hát az biztos hogy a kommunizmus nem
segített nekünk abban hogy felmerjünk
szólalni igen ez mindenkire ragad ez ez
rám is ragad mer én is ott nőttem fel
tehát ez mindenkire ragad tehát hogy ez
ezzen lehet dolgozni tehát ez ez nem
kell így nem kell hogy így maradjon azt
akarom mondani az otthoniaknak de az az
elég érdekes hogy hogy izraelbe több
mosolygó embert látok mint a háború
alatt is háború előtt é után is tehát
hogy ez ez nem nem azon múlik hogy
háború van vagy nincs háború és
és ez egy ilyan erőt ad tehát hogy ez
egy ilyen jó hangulatot ad mert
valószínű megvan az hogy hogy nem
tehetjük meg azt hogy hogy nincs jó
kezünk mert egy limitált idő van tehát
tudjuk hog tudjuk hogy hogy van egy
limitált idő amikor béke van h tehát
bármikor történhet bármi ha most nincs
gond akkor miért legyen rossz
kezünk a cikkedben említetted a túszokat
is hogy a
képüket kirakták nyomás helyeznek a
politikai vezetésre hogy minél hamarabb
szabadítsák ki a túszokat jelen
pillanatban 52 túsz van haó jól
emlékszem hány túz van még 100ról tudok
100ról tud lehet akkor 52 amerikai ami
eljut hozzánk a
médiába nem tudom én 100ró tudok de egy
része biztos hogy meghalt nem t én nem
tudom a pontos számukat hogy hány halt
meg de a az izraeli az izraeli kormány
is aztzem mondta hogy egy egy része
meghalt nem akarok olyan szám számot
mondani ami nem az ebben a pillanatban
most men milyen a közhangulat a
túszokkal szemben mármint hogy a
túszokért gondolom vannak-e tüntetések
mekkora nyomás vannak a tüntetések egész
évben voltak és szerintem lesznek is
tehát ez ez ez megint visszajövünk az
egységhez tehát hogy nem folytják
magukba az emberek ami ami bennünk van
tehát hogy a a a tuszok hiánya az úgy
képzel el olyan minthaog stivednek egy
részét kitépné egy politikusnak ez egy
nagyon nehéz helyzet tehát y ez egy ez
egy szinte nem tudsz helyes döntést
hozni semmivel mert mert mert egyfelől
akarod a tuszokat
kiszabadítani de de másfelől figyelembe
kell vegyed a hosszút távú
biztonsági érdekeit izraelnek
tehát visszamennék egy korábbi
történethez 2011-ben mikor először
jöttem ki lehet hogy hallottál róla gilá
sharit nevezetű katona azt hiszem
2006-ban hatban tuszul lejtették és öt
évet volt tusz a hamasz fogságában és
2011-re szabadult izrael kötött egy
alkut a hamasszal és 1zer valamennyi
bebörtönzött palesztint adott vissza
amikor olyan
300 nak a bűncselekménye
terrócselekményhez köthető hm
egy egy egyért adott ezzel valamennyit
és ez ennek nyilván hogy mindenki örült
hogy vissza t a mi katonánk meg meg én
emlékszem mikor először voltam itt ezek
így így bennem vannak hogy láttam a a
plakátokat például gilásá jottta hogy
milyen jó hogy
visszajött viszont van van egy másik
fele ennek a dolognak hogyha ha bármit
oda bármit odaad izrael akkor azzal azt
üzeni hogy hogy gyertek raboljatok meg
tőlünk tuszokat mert kaptok vissza
terroristákat tehát hogy érted tehát ez
egy nagyon nagyon nehéz dolog és az
izrael politikája jelen helyzetben az
hogy katonai nyomást helyez a hamasra és
a nyomás
következtében próbál visszaszerezni
túszokat de az az nem megy hogy a a
terroristákal nem lehet alkudozni ilen
nem úgy van mint európában hogy leülnek
egy asztalhoz és aláírnak két papírt és
akkor megtörténik egy alkó tehát itt a
papírnak nem sok jelentősége van
közelkelet ez egy ez egy valósabb világ
mondjam
így ez a és ez a helyzet hogy a hamász
élőpajzsként használja ezeket a a saját
embereit a a palesztin népet ez ez
gondolom még nehezebbé teszi a a
helyzetet igazából ez az ami nagyon
nehézzé teszi a helyzetet megfogtad a
főpontot
ezzel jelenleg most milyen a hangulat mi
mi mi a a a am m mik történnek úgy nap
mint nap gondolom hogy nap mint nap
követed a híreket hogy hogy melyek a
legújabb fejlemények az az igazság hogy
kevesebb híreket kell köves
mióta itt vagyok tehát mikor kint
voltamt kolozsváron értem vagy vagy
magyarországon akkor akkor több több
kirt olvastam mer főleg hogyha történt
valami konfliktus de itt itt meghallom a
szirénából a híreket tehát hogy hogy
hogy nem nem nem vagyok annyira
rákattalva valamelyik újságra hogy
olvassam meg megnézem nagyvonalakban és
másfelő meg facebookon vagy vagy más
hálózatokon hogyha fen vagyok akkor
szembe jönnek anélkül megerőltetni magam
egy csoportba tehát szembejönnek
megtudjuk hogy nem tudom egy hónapja
például beleállt egy rakéta egy egy
autóba egy törünk 20 km-re
tehát ilyen híreket megtudok hamarabb
tehát olyan hamar eljutnak hogy hogy a
még megs jelé az újságban is már megvan
tehát a csoportokban nagyon aktívak itt
az emberek értem kicsit beszélgessünk
magáról a hadseregről ugyanis ez
egy
érdekes felállás hogy a nőket is be
bevonják a hadseregbe tehát a nők is
kötelező hadsereg van kötelező sorozás
van a nők számára is erről egy kicsit
tudnál mesélni hogy ez hogyan működik te
kellett-e
ezen a sorozáson részt vegyél
besoroztak-e téged is nem nekem nincs
ilyen kötelezettségem mert én én úgymond
már öreg vagyok tehát hogy én 35 éves
voltam amikor kijöttem és ez a katonaság
az 18 évtől kezdődik és a fiúknak
nagyjából három év és a a nőknek két év
igazából izraelben
egyetem előtt úgymond katonák lesznek az
emberek h ami ami én azt látom hogy
érettebb embereket termel ki a
társadalomn tehát
hogy a mi esetünkben ilyen ilyen a a mi
rendszerünk ilyen okost tónikat neve
hogy kimegyünk a liceumból és akkor
megyünk egyetemre és ülünk a könyvtárba
és tanulunk szesszió tehát ilyen ilyen
okostónik leszünk de nem
nem leszünk
érettek és itt itt előbb lesznek az
emberek érettek és utána utána jobban
megtöltik a fejiket tudásra azt látom ha
most visszamehetnél cikseradai időkbe
akkor inkább vállalnád a
katonaságot én azt hiszem hogy nem ártal
sem nekem sem általában sem
nekem én magamról beszélek hogy nekem
biztos hogy nem ártott volna hogyha
lettem vol igen érdekesen alakult volna
az életünk hogyha mind a ketten azt a
határozottságot ahogy az emberek
fellépnek itt hogy mennyivel
lazábban kezelnek helyzeteket mert sok
krízishelyzeten átmennek tehát hogy
ilyen kicsi dolgokat sokkal azábban
kezelnek
érezhető és sok sok
cégvezető úgy kerül ki hogy a felismerik
már a katonaságban hogy ő alkalmas a
vezetésre iss ezért egy cégnek a
vezetője ez később például tehát itt
izraelben hogyha leadod a cégédet és és
te fel tudod mutatni hogy nem tudom
melyik egységbe te vezér voltál
katonaság az egy sima előny például hm
y kicsit mesélj a nőkről is a
a katonaságnál hogy ők ők milyen
pozícióba harcol mit lehet tudni róluk
hogy hogy hol lehet a nőket használni
egy ilyen
konfliktusnál tudomásom szerint a nők
nagyjából betölthetik a 80%-át a létező
pozícióknak a katonaságon belül
katonaság nem csak abból áll hogy hogy
valaki harcol gázábaan hanem felügyelni
kell dolgokat izraelbe is
például mondom ény hol szoktam nőket
látni például szoktam a jeruzsálemi
utáin nőket látni akik akik fegyverrel
járnak
és nyilván azért felelnek hogy a
lakosság biztonság legyen az utcákon
vagy vannak ilyen checkpok például mikor
mikor valaki jön be jeruzsálembbe akkor
van egy checkpoint mert vannak a nem túl
messze a checkpointok a palesztin
területek és nem mindenkinek van joga
bejönni jeruzsálembe vagy vagy bizonyos
engedélyel van joga bejönni és ott is
sok nőt szoktam például látni
de a legtöbb pozícióban nincsen kolnát
tehát hogy nők is lehetnek hogyha ha nem
túl reprezentáltak a nők valamilyen
pozícióban az nem feltétlen azért van
mert korlátozza valaki hanem ez egy
ilyen természetes ösztön hogy hogy a a
férfinak férfinak kellő menni bizonyos
főleg a veszées pozíciókban de például
vannak újabban azt hisem vannak pilóták
akik
nő a civil lakosságnak civil lakosságnak
fegyvertartási engedélye van-e van de
nagyon szigorú
procedúra akik katonák voltak azoknak
azoknak aránylag könnyű megkapni mert
tapasztalattal rendelkeznek de de hogyha
mondjuk én akarnék kapni akkor akkor egy
nagyon szigorú procedúrán keresztülkell
menjek tehát akkor nem egy gyakori hogy
valakinek fegyvere van otthon de
izraelben izraelben egy gyakori mivel
hogy nagy a nagy a lakosság azon része
aki volt már katona tehát hogy ezért
elég gyakori de de de nem dobálják csak
ugy a fegyvert és függ függ a a
településtől tehát hogy például mennyire
élsz veszélyes településen tehát hogyha
egy olyan helyen néz ahol senki nem
parcol meg tégel akkor nem biztos nan
könnyen könnyen
kapsz fegyvert mert te csak akarsz
vagy könnyebben adnak fegyvert egy olyan
helyen aki aki egy veszélyesebb zónáb
alé például tehát ez sok sok sok
paraméter
függvénye például azz egyik
alapkövetelménye hogy én tudom hogy
héber nyelvet azt folyékonyan beszéled
hm tehát miközben fegyver van a kezedben
elég fontos hogy megértsed hogy
körülötted mi történik vagy ha valaki
rádordít vagy ki mit beszél egy másik
fegyveres esetleg mit mond neked tehát
ez ezek ilyen alap alapdolgok tehát hogy
ez ez példá egy alapkövetelmény azt
hiszem van valami ilyasmi is hogy mennyi
időt étér itt meg megm sok-sok paraméter
összeget te az gondolkozszá azon hogy
beszerezz egy fegyvert magadnak hogy meg
tud védeni magad a
családodat szerintem idővelbe is fogok
állampolgárság tervben van-e hogy
felvedd a zsidó állampolgárságot
igen igen az az egy folyamatnak a a
része mivel hogy a izraelben az a
szabály hogy a az aliászat aki akinek
nagyapjáig vagy a nagyanyjáig zsidó
gyökerei vannak és nekem nem ez az eset
nekem egy kicsit fennebb van ezért ezért
én egy más procedúrával jöttem ide de de
hosszútávan lehetséges lesz
igen az egyik ok amiért kérdeztem ezt a
a a nőknek a szerepét így a a
hadseregben engem teljesen megdöbbentett
amikor utánanéztem izrael szaporulati
indexének én arra számítottam hogy mivel
a csapból is ez folyik európában a
szaporulati index
1,3 1,5 vagyis hogy két ember után
másfél gyermek születik és hogy ez egy
általános probléma hogy hogy nincs kedve
a nőknek gyermeket szülni úgy én
intuitívan arra gondoltam hogy talán
pont ugyanez a helyzet izrael ben is
hogy hogy egy háborús környezetben ott
ahol a nők is katonák valószínűleg nincs
annyira kedvük gyermeket szülni és
megdöbbentem hogy ez 2,6 vagy 2,9
2, eszméletlen hogy két ember után 2,9
gyermek születik kicsit mesélnél erről
hogy ez hogy lehetséges mi a véleményed
hogy hogy mi az oka annak hogy európában
alacsony a szaporulati index és és
izrael ebben egy háborús országban
viszont magas
azt hiszem hogy ez egy kulturális meg
jóléti kérdés is tehát
ennek is több paramétere van
de itt elég gyakori tényleg elég gyakori
a sok gyerekes család tehát
egyrészt attól függetlenül hogy valaki
mennyire vallásos ez a valagy olyan a
zsidó vallásból ami megérződik a nem
vallásosokan is tehát telavéban is simán
vannak olyan családok akik akik
egyáltalán nem vallásosak és van négyö
gyerek át nem nem nem annyira ritka de a
a három az az elég gyakori tehát az az
átlagot az az az nagyjából jól van
kiszámolva azt hiszem a
2,9-es és nyilván van az a része a
társadalom akinek nulla van vagy vagy
vagy egy kettő de de másik felől van egy
nagyon nagy vallásos közösség és a a
vallásos zsidóknál előful a 910 én
beszéltem egy olyan rabbival akinek 13
gyereke van
p tehát hogy így ezekből ezekből jön ki
az átlag de megtalálsz minden skálát
megtalálszen tehát akkor most azt nem
értem h akkor a vallás szerepet játszik
ebben vagy nem játszik szerepet szerepet
játszik a vallás de amit akarok mondani
hogy hogy
a ha valaki nem direktbe és vallásos a
vallás az része a kultúrának tehát a
valahogy ez így átadódik kimondat
áttitatja a hétköznapokat pos ugyanolyan
mint hogy hogy van a sabbat például
sabbat egész elég csá van főleg
jeruzsálemben egy nagyon nagy
különbséget ézz de az izrael többi
részén is de a legszembbe tűnö talán
jeruzsálemben és úgy oké a vallásosok
tartják ezt úgy szigorúan de de valahogy
neked se jön hogy olyan olyan nagy
dolgokat csinál amikor mindenki csendben
van tehát neked se jön hogy nem
tudom tehát ilyen szempontból annak
ellenére hogyha nem is vagy vallásos
valamilyen szinten kapsz eő a
dolog az életszínvonal tekintet tekintve
pont azt látom hogy minél magasabb
életszínvonaló él egy ország itt
európában annál kevésbé valószínűbb hogy
több gyermeket vállalnak a a nők igen
tehát a gazdag országok ahol kevés
gyermek születik de izrael is egy gazdag
ország
igen izrael y drága ország és drága
ország tehát akkor ez ez hogyan
befolyásolja tehát ezek szerint akkor
mégsem befolyásolja legalábbis izraelben
nem látszik ez van egy demográfiai
háború is mondjuk úgy tehát hogy a az
arblak ág is nis eg egész
tehát hogy sok gyermeket
szülnek
emiatt van egy demográfiai háború is én
úgy gondolom ez nem kimondva vagy
kimondatlanul tehát hogy nem szabad
úgymond túlszüljenek minket van egy
ilyen
háború nem hívjuk háborúnak vagy lehet
hogy ezt nem nem beszélnek így róla ezt
ezt csak ín mondom így de de ez bennem
van valahogy másik oka azt hiszem hogy
hogy mivel ez egy egy veszélyesebb tp
tehát a szülők hogyhasak a szülők
szempontjából nézem akkor
lehet hogy csúnya ezt így mondani de van
egy diverzifikáció mert hogy gyerekeidet
hogyha elküdött katonának bármi
megtörténhet és ha csak egy van
akkor akkor az fájdalmasabb minthogyha
ötből mindegyik fájdalmas nyilván de
hogyha ez ez lehet hogy csúnya dolog így
kimondani de ez ez össztönösen benne van
szerintem az
embererek tehát az iporosodás előtt ez
pont így történt a európában is hogy a
ami amikor az élet ennyire kegyetlen
volt hogy egy átlag férfi 40 évet élt
körülbelül és járvány és mindenféle
háborúk és éhénységek elvitték az
emberek nagy részét hogyha csak két
gyermeked volt nagy valószínűséggel
te is nehéz helyzetbe kerültél amikor
idősebb korodba értél emiatt vállaltak
öt-h gyermeket átlagba az iparosodás
előtt de pont hogy az iparosodás ez
hozta ezt a a biztonságot hogy szinte
egy gyermek sem hal meg
manapság szülés után az első egy fél
évbe míg ezelőtt a gyermekhandóság ez
hatalmas volt most pedig a higiéniai
körülmények és az orvosi
ellátás miatt gyakorlatilag
statisztikailag nem szignifikáns a
gyermekhalandóság viszont érdekes hogy
ez újra visszajön egy háborús
környezetbe hogy ahogy mondtad mond
kimondatlanul is a nők emiatt vállalnak
több gyermeket de ehhez hozzá kell
jááruljon az egész társadalom ugyanúgy
tehát hogy a a nőknek a szerepe mint
anya bizonyos
szempontból fel van emelve pontosan
izrael egy nagyon gyerekbalát ország
tehát hogy bárhova mész elmész egy
vendégbe egy hozzák oda a gyerekkel vagy
hogy kényelmesen őjön tehát hogy nagyon
figyel repülőtéren vagy egyből előre
hívnak hogy ne ken sorbáljál tehát hogy
ugyanúgy amit amit felolvastál a a
hargita népés cikkből hogy hogy igen van
egy erős ország meg egy erős hadserg de
van a mögötte egy egy erős társadalom
aki akit érdeklik ezek a dolgok tehát
hogy hugye ez sosem úgy alakul ki hogy
hogy politika elün valamit és akkor most
legyen sok gyerek tehát hogy vannak
helyek európában is ha próbálkoznak de
ez nem hogy is mondjam nem feltétlenl
működőképes mikor a politika azt mondja
hogy most szűljenek tehát érted hogy ez
ez ez egy alulról jövő dolog kell hogy
legyen seresn úgy látom nem egy felőről
felőről erő erőltetett dolog tehát itt
izraelben én nem nem is láttam ilyen
dolgokat hogy ilyen ilyen ilyen
plakátokat mint a hogy hogy valakit
bíztatni kellene erre vagy
ilyesm nyilván mindenkinek megvan a
magán élete meg mindenki annyit vállal
ahogy ahogy gondolja de de ez
általánosságban ez ez itt egy ilyen egy
ilyen természetes dolog hogy hogy sok
gyerekes családok vannak meg emiatt a
társadalm is fiatal meg ilyen nagyobb a
nyüzsgés a társadalomban tehát hogy itt
jobban érzed az életet tehát hogy minden
gyors minden dinamikus
bárhova bész ömlenek az emberek jönnek
nagyon sokan
zajosak tehát ilyen nekem ilyen jó
hangulatot ad mondj amúgy tehát ilyen
érzed az életet izraelben mikor ha
európába elmész bárhova és nem beszélek
csak romániáról meg meg magyarországról
hanem érzesz egy ilyen slow motion
slow motion életérzést és valószínűy ez
az oka hogye megtalálni egy
pesszimizmust is igen igen egy ilyen
elöregedés jellemzi a társadalmakat de
nem csak korban hanem mentálisan is
lehet gondolod hogy egy háborúra lenne
szükségünk hogy
felébredjünk nem tudom ezt így
kijelenteni egyértelműen hogy szükség
van-e
háborúra nyilván nem kívánatos de azt
hiszem hogy a háborút azt azt
azt
mint nem is tudom hogy mondjam neked ezt
úgyhogy
úgyhogy valósan adjám át de kitermeljük
a háborút azt kitermeljük tehát hogy én
én hát mindenesetre egy krízishelyzet
amiben felmerül a a legmélyebb
kérdésekre fel merülnek fel miért élünk
és mi tart össze minket merre tart a
nemzetünk mit kell feláldozzunk azért
hogy együtt maradhassunk ezek mindmind
felmerül nek m kérdés igen
a háború az egy olyan mint egy reset
mint egy reset gomb én úgy úgy fogom fel
tehát hogy hogy van egy békés idő amikor
az egók túl nagyra nőnek egymásnak
feszülnek és valahogy az ki kell oltani
ezt a konfliktust és akkor van egy
háború és akkor utána van egy ilyen
reszet és akkor az emberek értékelik a
békét és akor megmuták a békét akkor
kezdenek megint háborúzni tehát ez egy
ilyen ilyen hullám és európában az van
hogy hogy most van van egy orosz-ukrán
háború meg volt korábban háború a
balkánon de az utóbbi pár 10 évben nem
volt olyan sok háború európában
szóval szóval emiatt így az embereknek
ez az alapértelmezett állapota hogy hogy
béke van és ez nekünk kijár és és emiatt
azzal vannak elfoglalva hogy egymással
harcolnak meg unatkoznakor a netflix is
unalmas akkor kezdenek egymással
harcolni felosztad ezt a fegyverviselési
engedélyt tehát hogy hogy
hogy mennyire szigorú izraelben tehát
izraelben nem azért szigorú mert attól
félnek hogy hogy mi egymást lelőjük
feltétlenül tehát inkább kompetencia
miatt de amerikáb amerikáb a
fegyverviselés attól szigorú mert az
amerikaiakat egymástól fézik hogy
lelővik egymást igen igen tehát hogy a
hogy sok sok elkényelmesedett érzelmileg
n felnőtt ember nem tudja kezelni a
kríziseit is elborul az agya és fes et
csinál fegyveréve és itt itt mivel van
egy olyan társadalom aki aki már fiatal
korától krízist kezelne kiált egy
katonaságot azért a az a fegyver egy
érettebb embernek a kezébe kerül
izraelben mint amerikában azt gondolom
egy kicsit beszélgessünk az
antiszemitizmusról hogy minthogyha
nyugaton újra fellángolt volna furcsa
módon egy
antiszemitizmus te ezt hogyan látod
hogy hogyan jelenik meg most így például
amerikában én én erre nem számítottam
hogy a nyugati egyetemeken elkezdenek a
palesztin ügyért tüntetni és antiszemita
megjegyzések zászlóégetés és durvábbnál
durvább kifejezések mert azt hittem hogy
ez auschwiic után nem lehetséges
többet te ezt hogy látod m azt gondolom
hogy a van egy olyan téma és pont ez az
antiszemitizmus ami amiben valahogy a
széslső bal és a szélső jobb az összeír
tehát ha megnézzük általában a sok más
témában a szélső jobbat meg a széső balt
akkor teljesen ellenkező véleményeket
mondunk az egyik vegetáriánus másik
húserő a az egyik globalista a másik
nagyon lokál patriota teszem fel vagy
vagy pont az ellentétét mondja
antiglobalista
a még számtalan ilyen téma van amiben
pont az ellenkezőá de nagyon érdekes
hogy van ez az antiszemitizmus témája és
ebben ők pont
egyetértenek és ez ez nekik is kíos
kimondani tehát hogy egy időben
a a szélső jobbra volt jellemző az
antiszemitizmusokban és most úgy úgy
költözik át tehát ez egy ilyen et egy
váorcizmus tehát hogy ez ez így megy
egyik oldalról a másikra és ez hogy
lehetséges hogy most a a tehát a szélső
jobb hogy hogy tudjeg együtt érten
egyetérteni a szélső ballal tehát
például ezzel a ne marxista
balliberális
vk társaság hogy mitől vált
antiszemitává a szélsőban hogy mitől
vált antiszemitává úogy an
anticiionistaett úgy vált antiszemitává
hogy megkérérezzi a zsidóság jogát
izrahez péá de mi köze ennek a a
balliberális oldalnak a
zsidósághoz hát egy időben a
valliberális oldal hangoztatta azt hogy
ő mennyire véd zi a zsidóságot meg ő
mennyire fellép az antiszemitizmus ellen
lehet volt egy része amelyik szívből
csinálta de volt egy része amely csak
azér csinálta mert így jól nézett ki
kamerák előtt jól nézett ki hogy azt
mondja hogy ő ő védelmezi a zsidóságot
meg meg olyan intellektuálisnak tűnt a
az illető akkor lehet de de hogy ahogy
teltek a az évek
úgy ők átmentek ebbe a
áldozati szeretben mondja amúgy tehát
hogy hogy a
most az lett a trendi hogy hogy hogy a
palesztinokat védelmezzü nagyon és tehát
ez köti össze akkor ezt látod hogy a
palesztinok is áldozatok és a
transszexuálisok is áldozatok és mivel
mind a ketten áldozatok ezért fogjunk
össze az elnyomó
fehér keresztény heteroszexuálisok
ellen van van van egy ilyen ilyen részre
is visszamennék október 7-re innen
jobban megnéjük talán hogyha teszünk
egép és visszafele tehát a október 7-én
sok izraeli zászlót láthattunk tehát
hogy nagy volt ez az empátia a világ
sokan meg akarták mutatni hogy együtt
éreznek izraellen meg milyen csapás
milyen tragédia történt itt és
ez így így tartott is vagy egy-két napot
tehát hogy és még izrael csak nem is
válaszolt már megjelentek a tüntetések
tehát a palesztin párt és izrael ellenes
tüntetések már megjelentek még izrael
csak nem is válaszolt izrael
é dolgozta ki a stratégiáját hogy hogy
hogy egyrészt az elején ki kellett a
hamaszt takarítani innen akik bejöttek
izraelbő és utána kezdett izrael
aktívabb lenni
és nagyon érdekes hogy a a világ nagyon
szeret sajnálkozni azon a zsidón akit
valami tragédia ér tehát ezt nagyon
szeretik de a kérdés az hogy valójában
minket sajnálnak-e ők vagy vagy csak meg
akarják mutatni hogy milyen jó emberek
és hogy ők mennyire mennyire sajnálnak
mennyire együtt éreznek és ők mindig
ráugranak az aktuális együttérző trendre
én ezt érzem és akkor utána izrael
kezdett válaszolni és akkor ne ők úgy
érezték hogy ők akkor fognak a mi még
inkább jó embernek tűnni hogy akkor ők
elkezdik a palesztinokat sajnálni most
és itt igazából nem aestinokról szól meg
a zsidókról a a dolog az ők
szempontjukból hanem hogy ők hogy
tűnhetnek jobb embernek hogy tudnak
jobban jó
emberkedni hm hogy tudják ezt ők jobban
megmutatni
kifele és a a szélső jobb az egy egy más
szempontból közelítette meg régebb az
antiszemitizmus most is csak most ilyen
nem hívja antiszemitizmusnak hanem ilyen
hogy is mondjam antiglobalista mondjuk
így tehát a a szélső jobb is egy
áldozati szerepet játszik csak olyan
szempontból hogy ő azt mondja hogy hogy
a zsidók uralják a világot médiát
bankokat és akkor azért mi azért vagyunk
szegények mert mert a zsidók elv tőlünk
amúgy ez nem
igaz nem nem gondolom hogy hogy a
zsidóság arányaiba véve sikeresebb mint
bármelyik nép arányaiban sikeresebb ez
ez ezen ez ezzen nem vitatkozot de de
azt amit ilyen túlzásokkal ők állítanak
az nem igaz tehát hogy ugye tehát ő ők
úgy mutatják be mint hogyha most
izraelben itt egy ilyenen 100 dolláros
al fújnám ki az orromat tehát ők úgy
próbálják a zsidóságot elemutatni érted
tehát hogy itt mi s ukába dobáljuk a
pénzt meg nem tudjuk hogy mit csináljun
jól érünk és az a pénz onnan van hogy mi
elvettük tőlünk lenyomtuk kiszíattjuk
tőlün igen hát most hogy az ördög
ügyvédjett játszam egy picit lehet mint
csik
szeredai tényleg nem 100 dollárosba
fújod az orrot de vannak van egy pár
zsidó egy szűk kisebbség aki viszont
birtokolja a vagyonnak a nagy
többségét tehát hogy hogy ezt mondanám
kérdezzek vissza miért fontos hogy
zsidó miért fontos hogy zsidó azért mert
aránytalanul úgy tűnik hogy aránytalanul
sokan vannak és ez egyből ha most
tényleg az ördögügyvéét akarom játszani
gyanússá teszi ezt hogy miért pont
zsidók ezek a személyek mondok egy
létező okot szerintem a zsidóság egy
intellektuálisabb vallás több
intellektuális embert termel
ki akikm a zsidó kultúrában fontosabb a
tanulás fontosabb a gyerekeknek a
tanulása mint annál hogy autót vegyünk
neki
például és a nepotizmus mennyire
jellemző a zsidókn hogy ő pártolják azt
hogy a zsidó inkább zsidónak adjon
lehetőséget vagy a rokonoknak tehát hogy
ez a
másik mondjam úgy hogy hogy hogy ítélet
a zsidók fölött hogy hogy önmagukat
emelik fel párt azt tudom mondani hogy a
magyarokat
románokat lengyeleket ebben mi
akadályozza meg hogy ők nem ugyanezt
csináljá tehát hogy tehát olyan olyan ez
ez inkább úgy érzem hogy akik ez ezt az
évet hozzák rog inkább irigykednek arra
irigykednek arra hogy hogy mi
egységesebbek vagyunk vagy hogy mi
szeretünk egymásra dolgozni vagy
szeretünk egymásnak trzakció egymással
tranzakcionálni mondjam tehát
ezt én is szeretem csinálni én
szívesebben dolgozok egy egy zsidóval
mint mint
mint valaki olyannal akinek nem tudom
hogy mik a céljaim mondjam hogy e nem
egy kizáró dolog energ csá hogy ez
kizáró dolog de én én
például 10 éve csak is zsidó al
dolgozok egymásal tranzakcionálom hm és
e ez ez nem egy ilyen ilyen vallási
dolog vagy egy ilyen
ideológiai belii dolog hogy én ezt most
így bevertem a fejembe vy valami ez ez
természetesen ti ez egy pragmatikus
döntés akkor a te életedben mert
könnyebben megérted magasabb a bizalmad
azok iránt akiket érted hog hogyan
működnek igen én példáó nem szívesen
termelek egy olyan valakinek pénzt aki
nem tudom hogy hova rakja lehet hogy
lehet hogy a palesztinoknak fogja od
leküldeni gázába és abból rakéta fogja
kijönni nem szívesen azok tehát most h
ha jönne nem tudom egy ilyen
valamilyen gazdag sek aki több pénzt
aján akkor valószíűleg elutasítanán nem
dolgoznék neki
és ez nem attól hogy én nem tudom milyen
morális lennék vagy hogy hogy valamilyen
ideológiákat gyártanék n magamb hanem ez
egy pragmatikus döntés igen és hasonló
hasonlókat vonzanak én azt gondolom
tehát
tehát számomra sokkal jobb érzés hogyha
ha én valami pénzt termelek hogyha az
egy olyan olyan tulajdonosnak megy a
zsebébe aki tudom hogy hogy izrael párti
ez egy fontos szempont izraelnek
vannak-e szövetségesei mármint hogy így
a politikában lehet hallani hogy például
amerika egyik szövetségese izraelnek de
ha ha tényleg így van ahogy mondod hogy
mintogyha izrael saját magára
számíthatna
igazi szövetséges se van-e így az
országok
közötti nehéz ez erre egy jó választ
adni tehát hogy látszólag vannak tehát
vannak országok akik
politikailag is kiállnak de mindig
érdemes megvizsgálni hogy az miért miért
teszi az az ország tehát hogy hogy jóban
van a két miniszterelnök esetleg azért
vagy vagy valamilyen érdeke van egy
országnak a másikkal és akkor akkor
közben játszza hogy izrael mellett van
de leváltják a kormányt és hirtelen
ugyanaz az ország már nem nem barátja
izraelnek mi a helyzet amerikával
összességében azt gondolom hogy egy
lefele mutató tendenciát mutatnak a
kapcsolatok egy ilyen lassú lefelemenő
tendenciát mutatnak viszont most most
hogy trump visszajön valószínű lesz egy
ilyen pozitív felhivel is mondjam úgy ez
ez ez úgy képzeled el mint a a lej
dollárá ár foolyamot hogy a lej
folyamatosan gyengül a dollárhoz képest
nyilván annak felivelései a lejnek hogy
valamelyik időszakba kevesebb leet
nyomtattak és több dollárt de attól még
a tendencia azott tendencia tehát hogy
hogy
most azt hiszem hogy obamával volt egy
ilyen mélyponton a a az izraeli amerikai
kapcsolatok
és joe biden hát ő egy
ilyen ő vele se voltak túl jók a
kapcsolatok mert kommunikációbaal
támogatja izraelt meg meg kap izrael
dolgokat de de izraelnek nem elég hogy
több fronton vív háború tehát hamasz
hezbolla hutik jemenből néha lőnek egy
pár
rakétát közbe kell figyelnit hogy ne
legyen terrortámadás közbe júdeából
samariából
a próbálnak próbálnak
terrorcselekményeket elkövetni tehát
nagyon sok rondon háborút ví és emellett
a a nyugati közvélemény is izrael ellen
fordult és
emellett az amerikai adminisztráció is
úgy kezdett viselkedni hogy próbálta
miközben izrael harcol próbálta fogni a
kezeit hogy ne nagyon csak úgy egy
kicsit jó tehát hogy érted tehát hogy ez
egy ez egy nagyon nehéz helyzet
nagyon nehéz helyzet a izraelnek a
vezetőének lenni hogy amúgy tehát hogy
nagyon sok mindenre kell mondoljá tehát
hogy most így elgondoltam magamban hogy
európában bármelyik országnak van egy
vezetője
és intézi a gazdasági ügyeit rakéták
nincsenek közben kimegy dumál egyet az
unióba egyet harcolnak nem tudom
hazamegy valami döntéseket hoznak emelik
a nyugdíjat nyomtatnak még pénzt nem
tehát érted amit mondok vannak ilyen
kaliberű problémák é vannak olyan
kaliberű hogy hogy több fronton harcolsz
nyugati közvélemény ellenet van
kisország vagy tehát hogy valamilyen
szinten függsz ettől a ettől a ezektől a
az országokó pá mint amerika esetleg egy
olyan adminisztráció van amerikában
amelyik amelyik veled ellentétes
politikát képvisel tehát az az érdeke
hog te megbukjál tehát és még az
országon belül tüntetnek is és az
országon belül tüntetnek az országon
belül is tüntetnek és még tuszok vannak
akiket ki kellene szabadítsá de úgy
kellene kizabadítsad hogy az ország
hosszútávú érdekeit azt azt azt szemelő
tart natanut mennyire fogadja el az
izraeli
nép milyen a népszerűség index ja a
választott miniszterelnök tehát hogy van
egy megosztottság
tehát mint itt úgy van van egy olyan
mondás hogyha egy vagyunk egy egy
szobában van két zsidó akkor van három
vélemény van egy ilyen mondás ezt a
székelyekre is mondják hogy
h vagy magyarokra tehát ez a ez a balhés
része megvan a politikának is tehát
hogyha megnézel egy parlamenti ülést
például izraelben akkor akkor sokkal
nagyobb alhékat sokkal nagyobb
bordibálásokat fogsz láni éké hogy nem
verekednek tehát hogy hogy sokkal jobban
nekimennek egymásnak a politikusok
és ugyan ugye ez a társadalomban is
megvan hogyha ha ha valamit csinál
miniszterelnök az az teljesen mindegz
hogy netáahu vagy nem
hogyha a népnek nem tetszik itt egy
kettőre 10 20 30 40000 ember megy ki
tüntetni tehát itt nem itt nem várnak
sok tehát hogy ahogy visszatérnék az
előző mondanivalómra hogy romániában
például egy probléma hogy a nép nagyon
nagyon sokat tűr tehát hogy csinál néha
egy ilyen rendszerváltást és akkor úgy
utána el egy 30-40 évigg minden jó van
és
akkor érted amit mondot tehát hogy hogy
a igazából a a a román társadalom akkor
megy ki az utcára amikor már éhes azt
gondolom az izraeli társadalom ez ez
hogy nem konfrontatív társadalom és az
izraeli társadalom mivel konfrontatív az
kimegy hamarabb és és én én én nem
akarok se ilyen jobb se jobb se bal
oldalra beállni tehát hogy én én
racionálisan figyelem a politikát nekem
nincsenek ilyen kedvenc politikusaim
vúyhogy valamelyiktől elolvadnék vagy
valamelyiket utáná nekem nincs ilen csak
próbálom a a társadalom szempontjából
analizálni és mivel izraelben van egy
ilyen társadalom aki úgymond a készt a
politikus nyakán tartja nem fikailag
mondom hanem politikai értelemben tehát
hogy hogy mindig nyomást helyez és a
politikus kell figyelni hogy mit csinál
mert nem lehet bármit megtenni mert mert
ez egy bhés nép it ezek egykettőre
kijönnek az utcára az egy más dolog
tehát például egy egy
alkotmánymódosításnál ami nem fekszik a
társadalom részének most függetlenül
attól hogy én egyetértek vele vagy nem
ez teljesen mindegy de látok egy látok
egy visszajelzéses a társadalm vagy azt
gondolja a társadalmom teszem fel most a
tuszokkal a tüntetésst hogy nem nem hely
helyezzi az aktuális kormány elé nem ad
elég prioritást annak hogy a tuszokat
kiszabadítsa hanem másokat prioritásra
és ő ezzel nem ért egyet akkor emiatt is
kimegy az utcára tehát és mik ezeknek a
tüntetéseknek a következményei
szétoszlatják a tömeget vagy pedig
bocsánatot ké a politikus ez ezek elég
által civilizált tüntetések én is volt
hogy részleten tüntetések tehát ezek
arról szól hogy beszédeket mondanak meg
hangsúlyozzák az ügynek a fontosságát én
én azeneén vettem részt éen tüntetés en
amikor még nem volt annyira túl
politikai mondjam úgy tehát hogy
olyan szempontból hogy támogatom az
ügyet a támogatom a tuszoknak az ügyét
kicsit legyen erősebb a hang ha egy
emberrel több van ott akkor legyen
erősebb az a hang tehát
hogy fontos hogy is mondjam tartani az
egyensúlyt hogy hogy
hogy ne nehogy azt gondolja valamelyek
politikus hogy ezt az ügyet el lehet
felejteni tehát ezért fontos hogy az
emberek kimennek és igazából én azt
látom hogy így lehet a politikusokat
jobbá tenni
hogy hogy nyomást helyez a társadalomra
ü például magyarországon meg romániában
ilyen nyomást énn nem lát nagyon
kényelmes politikusnak lenni azt kell
mondjam tehát hogy igen igen
valószínűleg kényelmesebb igen tizen
megváltoztathatják az
alkotmánytt néz nézz elmellette itt ha
belepiszkál valaki az alkotmányba nagyon
nehezen tudom elképzelni hogy nem megy
valakiki az utcába ha csak úgy
belepiszkál hogy hogy esetleg felmerül a
gyanúja annak a saját érdekében piszkál
az
alkotmányban mire számítasz január 20
után január 20 után
számítok egy csendesebb egy kicsit
csendesebb időszakra de én nem hiszek a
full békébe tehát én azt gondolom hogy a
full béke az egy illúzió de én ezt úgy
fogom fel mint egy menedzselendő helyzet
izrael számára tehát hogy valószínűogy a
trump administrációval könnyebb lesz
menedzselni ezt a helyzetet mint mint a
biden adminisztrációval volt tuszokat
szerinted el fogják engedni
nem tudok nem akarok ebbe tippelni
nagyon nehéz helyzet tehát hogy egyrészt
nem is nincs az összes 20 az összes túsz
a a hamasnál feltétlenül hanem különböző
terrors szervezetek vannak még
még még a gázán belül és ezeket
szétosztják
a sok esetben volt volt olyan tusz hogy
például családnál volt azt hiszem akit
az elején kiszabadítottak és valahogy a
titkos szolgálat
észrevette és kiszabadították volt olyan
eset is tehát hogy ők azért részben szét
is osztják és azt hiszem hogy részben
közel is tartanak maguk mellett egy
párat hogy ezér nekik ez ilyen ilyen
ilyen biztosításra tusszok ők így
gondolkoznak tehát hogy mikor már a
nyakuknak és a hámásznak akkor akkor
akkor hajlandlandóak az akkora tehát
hogy ő ezt ezért ezért csináljá
tulajdonképpen az egyik legnehezebb
dolog egy nagyon egy konfliktusos
helyzetben hogy a másik félnek a fejével
gondolkoz beszélgettünk és az az igaz ág
nekem nehezembbre esik most a hamas
mellett érvelni de ha most én
megkérnélek téged hogy te most mit
tudnál felhozni a hamas mellett mint
érv mi lenne a legerősebb érv amit fel
tudnál hozni mondtad hogy szereted
racionálisan megközelíteni a
dolgokat szeretem racionálisan
megközelíteni dolgokat politikailag tát
politikával szerintem nem érdemes sok
sok érzelmet rakni van jobb hely ahova
rakatjuk az érzelmeinket például család
barátok bármilyen emberi kapcsolatokban
jobb helyen vannak az érzelmek
minthogyha elolvadnánk egyik vagy másik
politikustól akkor gyere védd meg a
hamast lássam meg tehát nem tud nem
tudom nem tudom megvédeni racionálisan
elmondom amit racionálisan látok
nagyjából
tehát ahogy beszéltünk hogy
[Zene]
minden politikai vezetés mögött vagy
hadsereg mögött van egy társadalom és
van hasonlóság a kettő között és az az
igazság hogy a a a hamasz meg a a
palesztin társadalom között is van
hasonlóság ez egy ilyen csúnya dolog
amit nyugaton nem szeretnek kimondani
engem ilyen miatt le is tiltottak
például facebookon van egy oldal amit
futtatok és egy ilyen vélemény miatt
letiltottak tehát h így kilenc hónap
eltiltottak mert kilenc hónapra vagy
kilenc hónapja kilenc hónapja most most
azt mondják hogy visszaadják de még úgy
érzem hogy csak 3%-os hatásokal megy az
oldalra hogy az ahhoz képest hogy az
előtt ment tehát
a a mikor egy terrorcselekmény történik
például izraelben akkor azt látjuk hogy
ők ünnepelnek az úton például baklavákat
ztanak meg tehát buliznak efekt az úton
tehát hogyha ők itt egy terrorcsát
elkövethetnek és meghal néhány zsidó
akkor
néhány áldozat van akkor ők ők ezt úgy
élvezik és ünnepelnek és nem csak a
hamasz ünnepel tehát nem az van hogy a
hamas ünnep szobába hanem csatlakozik a
a társadalom tehát hogy ez egy ilyen
dolog október 7-én például nem csak a
hamas jött át nem csak a hamas jött át a
kerítésen hanem még csatlakoztak amivel
tudtak motorbiciklikkel meg mindenen
vannak videók tehát hogy hogy szeretik
nyugaton bemutatni ezt úgy hogy van egy
csúnya hamas és van egy ilyen nagyon
ártatlan
hópehely palesztin társadalom aki a
lénynek se ált csak a hamasz csú és ez
egy hazugság és hogyha ezt kimondod
akkor ezért elkaszálnak
úogy remélem hogy remélem hogy nem ér
baj a csatorná csatornál még az elején
hívtál be tehát
hogy innen innen nem nem lesz túl nehéz
újrakezdeni
úgyhogy kedves nézők hogyha lekapcsolják
a csatornámat akkor erős gáspára felelős
érte igen igen valahogy beszegíteek ha
lekapcsolnak akkor valami valamiegítek
de amit akartam mondani hogy ott is van
hasonló ág é például van egy egy
palesztin professzor aki az
értelmiségből mondom palesztin
értelmiségből aki csinált ilyen
felmérést hogy hogy öt hónappal mondjuk
az október 7e után hányan támogatják a
hamaszt a palesztin társadalomból és és
kött egy ilyen jó 80%
körül nem lehet hogy hogy félelemben
diktatúra diktatúrába tartják a a
palesztin népet próbálok érvelni
szóval hogy hogy hogy hogy nem lehet
hogy hogy kényszerből mond mondanak
igent a hamaszra a palesztin
társadalom hamaszt is valaki felnevelte
azok is valamikor ártatlan gyerekek
voltak akiket felneveltek és terroristák
letk belőle és valahogy ez a ez ez a
részük a része a kultúrájuknak sajnos ez
szomorú így kimondani de de ez része az
oktatásnak tereket nevez ek-e például
tereket neveznek-e
terroristákról meg h máz nyiltan is
kimondja hogy hogy nekünk zsidóknak itt
semmi helyük nincsen semmi helyünk
nincsen izraelben tehát ők a
palesztinoknak ez
a ők ezt mondják hogy from the river to
the se palestine tehát hogy a a a
jordánfolyótól egészen a tenger tehát h
ők nem akarnak itt zsidót látni ők
ők ők ezt úgy fogják fel hogy ez
teljesen az övé és é nekünk nincs jogunk
semmihez és nagyon n nagyonon tehát hogy
értem hogy akarod hogy valamiéret
felhozzak tehát hogyha ha meg valamilyen
szinten racionálisan megpróbálom
megközelíteni ez az hogy ha megnézem
hogy én hogyha valami csúnya dolgot
teszek akkor hogy tudok én fejlődni
tehát elősisztikus felelősséget kell
vállaljak a a tetteimért érzelmeimért
mindené felelősséget vállak és akkor
megnézem hogy mit tudnék én megjavítani
mi az amit én meg tudnék javítani és ha
ha hamasz tudna egy jó dolgot tenni
akkor az az lenne hogy szembenéz
önmagával meg ugyanúgy a palesztin
társadalom meg egyenként tehát hogy mit
mit tanítanak a gyerekeiknek például
nézzenek szembe azzal hogy jó-e hogy azt
tanítják hogy hogy a zsidókat el akarják
pusztítani és hogy hogy van-e van-e
egyáltalán esélyük nekik bármire hogyha
ha így gondolkoznak tehát hogy én értem
hogy államot akarnak meg mindent de most
most október 7e után
ö ha még volt valami esélyük az az aztán
még nagyon lecsökkent tehát hogy most
képzeld el hogy izraeli társadalom most
adjon egy államot nekik mert mert mert
azt mondjuk hogy na most akkor jó minden
rendben van mert sok idő elmúlt tehát
érted tehát hogy ez nem nem tudok
érveket mondani igazából nem tudok
érveket mondani az ő szempontjukból hogy
hogy hogy miért teszik ezt mert mert
izrael kivonult gázából kivonult
2005-ben i átadta a t kulcsot úgymond
gáában volt egy
választás 2007-ben megszavazták a hamas
van van egy másik egy fata van egy másik
politikai párt ő úgy dem megszavazták a
hamas és és ezt ezt menedzselték tehát é
én nem látom hogy hogyan blamálják
izraelt hogy ők azt csináltak kvázi
államként működhettek nem voltak
hivatalosan állam de azt csináltak amit
akartak gázának vannak egész jó
adottságaiik például eg szép
tengerpartja van tehát hogyha az egy
békés hely lenne akkor ott lehetne a
turizmust például virágoztatni üüm
sok mindent is termeltek tehát ott ott
nem tudom tudod- a történetet de de
2005-ben mikor izrael mikor izrael
átadta a kapakulcsot gázának akkor onnan
onnan a zsidókat
erőszakkal
vittek ki hogy átadják átadják nekik
hogy ez úgymond majd hoz egy stabilitást
érted és nem mondott és most képzeld el
hogyha te te laktál volna ott tehát én
mondok egy egy ilyen rövid történetet én
találkoztam egy olyan fiúval aki aki
gázában lakott és őt ő 10 éves volt azt
hiszem körülbelül amikor amikor
erőszakkal azt mondták nekik hogy el
kell hagyni mert ez az egyezmény és
gázatát adják a a palesztinoknak és most
képzel hogy eg gyerekkorodban így
kiveszik a szüzőházat alólad és azt
mondják hogy kapsz egy másikat valahol
máshol és eltelik 20 év 30 év és akkor
nézed hogy jönnek a rakéták és akkor azt
mondod hogy ezért kellett nekem elhagyni
a szülő a szülőházamat ezért kellett
átadni érted tehát hogy üüm ez ezek
nagyon kemény do és és láttam azon a
azon a film hogy ez egy ilyen nagyon
méren benne van tehát hogy beszéltem is
mert erről ez nagyon nagyon nagyon
milyen benne van hogy ezt így ez az
igazságtalanság igen ez az
igazságtalanság hogy érdemes volt az
akkori kormánynak ezt a dönté az akkori
izraeli kormánynak ezt a döntést
meghozni hogy hogy így erőszakkal mi mi
lett volna a keríté egy kicsit lenne
húzzák meg te szenepel hogy látod izrael
jövőjét a következő 5-10 évben ami ami
egy hihetetlen hosszú időnek tűnik ezek
között a körülmények
között én pozitívnak látom izraelnek a
jövőjét tehát hogy van egy olyan mondás
nem tudom melyik vezető mondta hogy ha
izraelbe be realista akarsz lenni akkor
hinned kell a csodág
hm tehát ez a ez a történelme izraelnek
tehát meg azt hiszem írtam
a megjelenik az újságcikben ez a mondás
a a amit olvashattál hogy hogy a zsidó
ünnepeket hogyha össze akarod foglalni
akkor az az hogy az úgy úgy szólna hogy
el akarta pusztítani minket győztünk
együnk nagyjából ez a ez ez az össz e ez
az összefoglalás de ebben benne van sok
minden benne van a mentalitás benne van
a a jövőre tekintés tehát a a zsidó
kultúra az életről szól
tehát amikor zsidó kultúráról beszélek
úgy képzeld el hogy hogy a itt a vallás
az nem egy olyan dolog hogy
hogy mint a sok keresztény vallásban
hogy az emberek elmennek vasárnap
templomba meghallgatnak valamit
hazamennek aztán vég aztán következő
vasárnap megint elmennek mermint ez ez
az élet része tehát ez egy a zsidóság az
egy életforma nem csak egy vallás egy
egy nemzet vallás is de de életforma
egyszerre és függetlenül attól hogy ki
ki mennyire vallásos mindenki kap egy
adagot ebből és mindenki megél egy
alagot ebbő
és innen jön ez a ez az optimizmus de
ezt az optimizmust ezt úgy mondanám hogy
ez valóságon alapuló optimizmus hogy a a
a mú nak a valóságán alapuló optimizmus
sokszor volt olyan helyzet hogy mindenki
jellenünk van és mégis izrael győzött és
mégis tovább mentünk és fejlöttünk és
virágzik az ország és még jobb lett
utána és akkor jött megint egy háború és
utána megint még jobb lett tehát hogy ez
ebben már van tapasztal tapasztalata a
zsidó népnek azt gondolom nincs benned
félelem azzal kapcsolatban hogy pár év
múlva egy rakéta eltalálja a lakásotokat
vagy az utcátokba kezdenek el gyilkolni
vagy most nem tudom milyen rém képet
mondjak hogy megijesztelek
téged
nincs rövid válasz tudom hogy ez ilyen
betegnek hangzik
de én én nem és nem nem vagyok semmilyen
hősedtől hogy ezt mondom tehát hogy ez
ez egy természetes őszinte válasz
részemől én tudtam hogy lesz háború
mikor kijöttem például én szüleimnek
mondtam amikor kijöttem szóltam elő a
szüleimnek hogy hogy valószínűle lesz
háború és majd ha majd háború lesz akkor
ne próbáljanak hazahívni mert nem fogok
éönni és a szüleid mond én én én nem
hülyítettem magam ezzel hogy itt itt
minden szép lesz meg béke lesz te én nem
úgy jöttem ki ide hogy hogy azt
gondoltam hogy na reméljük akkor nem
lesz semmi soha többé és mindenki
boldogan fog élni mert ez nem a realitás
és a sajnos ez nem a realitás a jövőre
se tehát hogy politikailag lehet
átmenetileg stabilizálni helyzeteket de
a nap végén az adott társadalmat
kitermel a háborút tehát hogyha ha x
embernek gyűlölet van a szívében az
kitermeli a háborút mindegy hogy
átmenetileg ki a politikai
vezető nem lehet a politikusokra fogni
mindent én azt gondolom tehát én ezért
ezért analizálom a társadalom
szempontjából és nincs realitás annak
hogy hosszútávú béke
legyen viszont átmenetileg amog béke van
addig örülünk neki addig ki kihozzuk a
maximumot belőle
igen hát köszönöm szépen ezt a
beszélgetést elérkezett az idő az utolsó
kérdésre mégpedig az lenne az utolsó
kérdésem hogy mit üzennél most már úgy
mondom hogy nekünk itt erdélyieknek itt
romániában akik
egy egy határnyira vagyunk a háborútól
és sokan félnek attól hogy mi történik
hogyha romániában is háború
lesz milyen
mentalitás az ami mit kell átvegyünk
tőletek ahhoz hogy ugyanezzel a a az
örömmel ezzel a vitalitással tudjunk
szembenézni a a a bizonytalan jövővel
egyrészt azt hogy nézzünk szembe a
realitásokkal tehát hogy ne hűítsük
magunkat tehát hogy hogyha ha azt
képzeljük el hogy hogy békereszt meg ez
kián nekünk ez ez nem igaz az hogy volt
egy ilyen
szerencsés pár éve amikor amikor nem
volt háború európában ez ez ez egy
ideális időszak de nem nem mag a
hosszútávú realitás tehát hogy
előbb-utóbb szerintem elképzelhetetlen
hogy ne legyen háború európában
mélyebben is én ezt nem tudom hogy mi
fogjuk-e érni vagy nem de valószínű lesz
tehát hogy hogy én csak annyit tudok
mondani hogy ilyennek a realitásb is az
instant fontos az instant reakció tehát
hogy azonnal reagálni és
nem nem áldozatot játszani ahogy izrael
teszi tehát hogy hogy reagálunk ahogy
tudunk összefogunk meg meg a jövőre
optimizmussal nézünk megtesszük a
magunké és nem engedhetjük meg magunknak
azt a luxust hogy férünk attól hogy most
most ahogy mondtam hogy becsapódott egy
rakéta hog 15 km vagy 20 km és akkor
most azon agyalok azon agyalok két hétig
hogy mi lett volna ha az én autómba
csapóz és mi lett volna hogyha pont
benne ülök a feleségem ezt a luxust ezt
nem lehet megengedni azt gondolom tehát
mentálisan fontos felnőni én ezt gond ez
a legfontosabb és a az ebből következő
cselekedetek fontosan mondok egy példát
most ha romániát vesszük vagy
magyarországot politikailag ugye a a
nato aki védi ez egyszerűen jó meg rossz
tehát egyszerre jó mert
úgymond nekünk most magamnak ellet
mondok nem kell katonának lenni tehát ez
ez az oka viszont ez egy darab papír egy
darab papír amíg nem volt kipróbálva ezt
még nem nem próbálta ki senki azt a
szerződést hogy hogy tényleg úgy
működik-e tényleg az ötös cikk úgy
érvénybe lépet tényleg tényleg amerika
annyira megvédi a romániát vagy
magyarországot ez e senkit nem szeretnék
kijzgetni ezért csak próbálok próbálok
valami realitást valami realitást átadni
vagy teszem fel ha ha a gy irán küldött
nekünk egy 200 rakétát legutóbb akkor
van-e hova bemenni lehet hogy lehet hogy
jó lenne úgy építeni az épületeket hogy
legyen egy ilyen biztonsági szoba
lehetne lehet jó lenne hogyha realitásba
élne a társadalom akkor lehet hogy jó
lenne ezen gondolkozni és lehet hogy nem
lenne a nagy probléma egy kicsit drágább
lakások de legyenek de de legyen egy
ilyen szoba hát én azt látom hogy ez
tudom hogy ez ilyen ilyen ijesztőnek
hangzik de azt látom hogy ezt jelenti a
realitásban élés hogy hogy nem hítjük
magunkat azzal hogy itt mindig béke lesz
meg az nekünk kiár és akkor ha ha ez
megvan akkor megengedet ük azt magunknak
hogy mosolygunk mert megtettük a
magunkét és akkor tudunk előrenézni ha
magunkat hülyítjük ha ha azt gondoljuk
hogy nekünk ez kiár akkor akkor csak egy
ilyen egy ilyen hazug frusztráció lesz
bennünk ezt tudnám üzenni tehát
szembenézünk a nehézségekkel önként
vállalva és most már ehetünk engedd meg
mondjak még egy példát neked tavaly
október 7-én volt a háború elmondom a
korrekt hozzáállást egy itteni példán
keresztül
október 7-én volt a háború és nagyjából
decemberben volt a hanuka a hanuka egy
ilyen egy ilyen vidám ünnep ahol
táncolunk meg zene van meg minden és
akkor felmerült a kérdés hogy illik-e
vagy vagy micsoda dolog az hogy hogy ott
vannak a tuszok meg izrael ilyen nehéz
helyzetben meg milyen sok áldozat van
hogy akkor akkor most most mi legyen
hanukán és a végülis a döntés az volt
hogy hogy az ünnep alatt én kint voltam
jeruzsáembtől történt egy megemlékezés
meg
meg egy ilyen egység felmutatása meg egy
bátorítás de megvolt a tánc is tehát
megvolt a tánc is ha gondolod elküld
valam videót bevághatod
ide jó küld el azt hiszem ez egy jó
zárókép lesz erre a igen azt hiszem hogy
ez egy jó zárókép lesz igen tehát hogy
ha át tudnám adni az izraeli mentalitást
akkor az az hogy decemberben táncoltunk
októberben egy nagyon nagyon nagy
tragédia történt ami örökre verelünk
lesz nem felejtjük el megemlékeztünk de
ugyanakkor előr nézünk és és egy olyan
ünnepet amit pár ezer éve
ünneplünk azt nem adunk fel a hamas
kedvére vagy az ellenség kedvé és ez a
hozzáállás és nem nem mondja senki hogy
jaj de most csúnya dolog vagy nem most
van az ideje majd jövőre v nem nem nem
nem engedjük meg magunknak ezt a ezt a
szépererdést vagy ezt a ezt a gyenge
mentalitást tehát nagyjából ezt tudnám
üzelni a videóban benne van minden
szerintem gazsi köszönöm szépen a
beszélgetést és nagyon hálás vagyok
örülök hogy ilyen formában is le tudtunk
ülni
és akkor jöjjön a
[Zene]
videóé ha tetszett ez a műsor akkor
iratkozz fel kérlek a csatornánkra ezzel
tudsz támogatni minket köszönjük a
vckker kávéközösségnek a jó kávéért az
ötvösudvarnak a helyért valamint a
bizalomtőkének a támogatásért nékületek
nem jöhetett volna ez létre